o pão justiça visa mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um superministro
link para quem por que eu queria que
vocês podem ver agora é que levantem
torta aqui mas prontamente para mim é
isso que vocês vão precisar fazer
primeiro um desafio muito cuidado e ser
muito responsáveis porque tem uma arma e
tem muita força
ok e próprio apesar de positivos de
picolé e agora muita gente deve estar
deste lado ok não tem política de picolé
agora não vou conseguir fazer isso um
dia se preocupa em solos não se não
tiverem precisar só de 48 podem sempre
comprar quatro lados
a mãe da maquininha vou comprar aqui os
lados o pai para pai e mãe pronta e um
pra mim é oque é bastante simples só vou
pensar sobre quatro é boa e vão precisar
de cortar dois pedaços pequenos como
este que o primeiro corta um coletinho
crie mais popular do montado por
sobrepõe uma parte à outra e corta um
chefe até bastante simples
apesar de cola e vou usar que comer
rápida mas se vocês não tiverem podem
usar outra qualquer e que isso não vai
fazer muita diferença neste caso é uma
vez que a gente vai pra mim também com
fita para forçar aqui conexão à web por
conta de um lado e vamos prender e que
um político medíocre pronto fica tudo
ali naquela extremidade alinhada e é por
causa do outro lado e alinhar lei
o outro polito vocês podem pensar que é
fraca estrutura mas não da posição dos
políticos é vocês vão ver que é muito
resistente aquém das 1500 cento entre
maio e este grande aqui três centenas
mais ou menos aproximar da can
agora vamos aqui por fita para forçar a
conexão por que vocês não quiserem fita
e quando for por dentro d'água vamos ver
o que acontece no momento em que algumas
escolas
pronto pronto vai ficar tudo mal vai
ficar uma porcaria e vai se estender até
então como você se esforçar e conexão
usando uma fita
agora vamos porque a água tem cuidado
para não queimarem e vocês vão mergulhar
ele o pontinho mais ou menos em dois
minutos por um bocadinho afastar um
cadinho por mais um ano a tentar afastar
mais um crime até ficar bom para vocês
conseguiram por um palito grande assim
desta maneira vamos buscar podem deixar
os carros não podem usar o secador que
os locais em que os centros é o buscador
é isso agora vão por causa das chuvas em
pequenino e introduzi la neste y com
cuidado e convém dar uma reforçada com
cola que ele na parte de baixo
depois é só tirar o que estiver seco
tirar o produto em grande e fazer agora
corte em v para os prendemos os
elásticos para não faltarem depois de
vários disparos é se vocês não tiverem
que os juizados podem usar uma faca bem
afiada mas usar sempre com cuidado podem
usar luvas vocês quiserem
antã nio ela não estava muito afiado
neste caso agora vão precisar de um todo
assim ele quebrou uma garrafa pet
mas aquela que tem e simon dolan são ok
vou pegar uma ondulação dessa bastante
pequenino e vamos fazer e pronto
bom era bom dar maneira que fique bom
para por lá podrinha que vocês quiserem
por lá eu sair do papel agora esta parte
se vocês forem pequeninos peçam ajuda um
adulto e que basicamente vocês vão
perceber que o tesouro se vocês não
tiverem uma tesoura com este podem usar
um prego e fazer isso os buraquinhos
aqui
desta maneira isso vai ficar muito
resistente não vai estragar passado
alguns pais estiverem pensar em fazer
com o tesouro os buraquinhos é bem e
deus não vou aguentar muito tempo e
espirros garcia
agora só por um milagre de um lado e do
outro e fazer dois pequeninos nós pronto
um lado ao outro do outro
agora aí depois de fazer isso é só
porque no y y como é que se chama também
a gente comentar frontal já está feito
agora é só tirar pronto não se esqueçam
de ser muito cuidadosos yazaki papel aí
pois puxa fita a volta quero ficar um
time mais pesado por ficar muito levo
não vai muito longe aqui e só esperando
estados estarão mesmo da xuxinha by
favorito e se inscreva no canal que
estudar ajuda bastante a divulgação ea
evolução é do meu trabalho e claro foi
uma sugestão vossa estiverem mais
sugestões do project é só deixar nos
comentários que agradecer mesmo a
presença no próximo projeto é preciso
outra vez políticos
então se vocês quiserem islate não se
esqueçam de igor daut porque o próximo
vídeo
os sinais que fazer esta super pistola
obrigado seu estilo e até à próxima
champions que é